[Applaudissements]
maintenant c'est w9 qui tient la corde
on sait pas encore sur quelle chaîne
savary ça pour être sur w9 très bien et
bar très bien on en saura plus très vite
alors on va parler maintenant des
victoires de la musique alors 2,9
millions de téléspectateurs qui rit
c'est plutôt faiblard faiblarde par
rapport à la concurrence ce soir là
c'est un peu mieux que l'année dernière
mais ce n'était pas le même jour et par
là même concurrencer exactement alors
cette année les artistes ont fait le
show sur le plateau des victoires
regardez oui gilles verdez excusez moi
mais vous ça fait un petit moment que je
vous regarde
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous connaissez ce
monsieur oui oui gilles où valérie
benaïm vous pouvez venir 1 minute venez
voir qu'est-ce qui s'occupe qu'est-ce
qui s'occupe de cyril hanouna
normalement c'est vous mokhtar qu'est ce
qui se passe ce monsieur n'est pas cyril
hanouna
ce monsieur n'est pas cyril hanouna
c'est le toucher le toucher le nom mais
c'est lui il lui ressemble et celui
montas il est où cyril hanouna ce
monsieur est un artiste transformiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même pas
regardez c'est la même barbare regarder
cela même barbe touche est touché c'est
la mer et cyril hanouna il est beau le
monsieur les par bull s'est passé
raymond n'est pas cyril hanouna
je vous assure regardez regardez les
cheveux mes cheveux c'est non c'est non
c'est pas la même texture même la voix
c'est pas lui le corps le corps et il
est où cyril mais je sais mais c'est un
artiste transformiste vous le connaissez
pas chaque touche nom et s'appelle en
garde en revanche pas je ne sais pas
comment il s'appelle un an c'est luis
herrero garder sa voix à la voir ça en
tout cas ça c'est magnifique
oui merci bien moooh gilou alors nous
sommes dans la victoire de la musique et
cette année les artistes ont fait le
show sur le plateau j'ai vous avez vu
les victoires de la musique
oh oui alors il y avait un duo de
présentateurs mais c'était deux nuls